2, 1
On November 18, 2023, Starship
took one step closer to Mars.
We have liftoff
One day, Elon Musk expects the most powerful
ever to carry 100 people to the red planet.
Unlike the previous test flight in April, this flight
achieved a milestone: Starship fired its engines
before detaching from the Super Heavy booster.
Stage separation
This complicated maneuver didn’t happen
previously, as a fuel leak led to a fire
in the booster, damaging many of its
33 engines. Starship veered off course,
and the team had to destroy it
over water for safety reasons.
And remember the damage to
the launch pad last time?
This time, SpaceX reinforced the launch pad with
a steel plate cooled by 260,000 gallons of water.
The plan was to lift off from Starbase in Boca
Chica Texas with the booster splashing down
close to shore while Starship soared before
landing in the Pacific Ocean near Hawaii.
However, as Elon is aware, not
everything goes according to plan.
Clip As you can see the super heavy booster has
just experienced a rapid unscheduled disassembly.
The booster exploded in spectacular fashion
after separating from Starship which is
believed to have self-destructed after the
team lost contact with it ten minutes in.
SpaceX says the lessons learned from this
flight will help improve Starship’s reliability.
After all, it took the Falcon
1 four tries before it reached
orbit and saved the company from impending death.
SpaceX even compiled a video showing all of its
failed attempts to land its orbital boosters.
If Mars were not the eventual target,
Elon would not need such a large rocket
that towers over the SLS and the
Saturn V that took us to the moon.
It’s more than twice the thrust of the Saturn V
- that’s the largest rocket to ever get to orbit.
He had already achieved remarkable success with
the Falcon 9 which has become the world’s most
reliable rocket, regularly transporting crew
and cargo to the ISS, a lucrative business.
But wealth was never the end game.
As Elon expressed in his biography
written by Walter Isaacson,
“I could have made a lot of money, but I
could not have made life multi-planetary.”
The Falcon 9 is not big enough or powerful
enough to go all the way to Mars. Not even
its larger sibling, the Falcon Heavy, can do that.
The Falcons are also not fully reusable.
While the first stage returns to Earth,
and the payload fairings are fished out
of the sea, the second stage is not recovered.
Starship is designed as a fully reusable rocket,
essential for long-duration missions, a capability
enhanced by its stainless steel construction.
Like the kind used on the Cybertruck.
Elon fell in love with stainless steel
a few years back, joking to his team,
“Stainless steel and I should
go get a room somewhere.”
Starship was originally supposed
to be made out of carbon fiber.
However, the carbon fiber sheets
were expensive and not up to the job.
Even the specialized expertise that went into them
could not prevent issues like developing wrinkles.
Elon knew that if they went
the carbon fiber route:
“This extrapolates to death. I’ll never
be able to get to Mars,” he told Isaacson.
So, inspired by the earliest Atlas rockets
that took the first Americans to orbit,
he opted for stainless steel.
It was an odd move according to his executive team
because stainless steel is
heavier than carbon fiber.
But Elon looked at the situation differently.
The high melting point of stainless
steel eliminated the need for as
many heat shields to protect Starship as it
re-enters the atmosphere…where temperatures
can soar as high as 1,500 degrees
Celsius, or 2,700 degrees Fahrenheit.
Fewer heat shields mean the
overall weight is reduced.
And stainless steel maintains its strength even
when holding supercooled liquid oxygen and
methane which is used to fuel Starship.
The first prototype of Starship was the Starhopper
which had retractable legs to test how
it could land when it returns to earth.
However, Elon has since decided to
try and to catch Starship - both the
ship and the booster - with the tower
that holds the rocket on the launchpad.
The SpaceX team was, once again,
nervous at such a bold proposal:
What happens if the catch fails and destroys
the launch tower and the next flight is delayed?
When someone on X asked why not just use the
landing legs for the booster, Elon replied:
“Legs would certainly work, but best
part is no part, best step is no step”
Highlighting his preference for
reducing complexity to bring down
costs and make space travel more affordable.
He’s applied the same principle to the design
of the Raptor engines that power Starship.
He wanted to lower the cost
of a single engine prototype
from $2 million to $200,000, cutting costs by 90%.
This strategy worked for him in the past
when he wanted to purchase refurbished
ICBMs from Russia but found the cost
of $8 million for one too high and
decided to create his own company
to build more affordable rockets.
He’s since coined the term “idiot
index” - a metric comparing the cost
of a component to the cost of its raw materials.
Let’s say the nozzle for the engine hypothetically
costs $20,000 but the raw material cost is $2,000,
the ratio on Elon’s “idiot index” would be 10:1.
A high ratio suggests the
production process for this
component is more expensive
than it really needs to be.
When Elon asked financial analyst
Lucas Hughes “What are the best
parts in Raptor as judged by the idiot index?”
And Hughes responded, “I’m not sure.”
Elon reamed him out. As reported
in Isaacson’s book, he said:
“You better be fucking sure in the future
you know these things off the top of your
head. If you ever come into a meeting
and do not know what are the idiot parts,
then your resignation will
be accepted immediately.”
Unbeknownst to Elon then, the
analyst had other things on his mind.
He had just lost a newborn
daughter a few weeks before.
Elon had suffered a similar loss when
his own firstborn, Nevada Alexander,
died of sudden infant death syndrome.
When Isaacson later asked Elon if he
felt he was being too harsh, Elon said:
“I try to criticize the action, not the person.
We all make mistakes. What matters is whether a
person has a good feedback loop, can seek
criticism from others, and can improve.
Physics does not care about hurt feelings. It
cares about whether you got the rocket right.”
The analyst was much more prepared the next day.
He discovered that parts with the highest cost
compared to raw material required
a lot of high-precision machining.
Elon decided that the person in charge of
each component should try to
get their costs down by 80%.
And if they couldn’t, they should “...step
aside if someone else might be able to do so.”
Elon has always operated with an extreme
sense of urgency as if every second counts,
declaring, “We need to get to Mars before I die.”
He assigned the responsibility for revamping
Raptor to a young engineer named Jacob McKenzie.
The directive, in Musk’s words, was to “...delete
any part that is even *potentially* unnecessary.”
McKenzie consulted a Tesla executive to
help streamline SpaceX's manufacturing,
drawing on how Tesla continuously streamlines
its process of mass-producing electric vehicles.
The result is that version 2 of the Raptor engine
removed many of the intricate plumbing
components and looked much simpler.
V1 looks kinda like a Christmas tree,
spaghetti pile. A lot of fiddly
bits. Raptor 2 costs about half
as much as Raptor 1 despite having much more
thrust…it’s only going to get better from here.
Elon’s hands-on approach is embodied by his
choice to live just a mile away from Starbase.
Despite being the richest person in the
world, he resides in a two-bedroom house,
where caffeine-free Diet Cokes are common, as
are midnight meetings with the Starship team.
Living and breathing the mission
to make life multi-planetary.
Building the most advanced rockets in the world
would not be possible without the
hard work of brilliant engineers.
If you’ve been inspired by Elon
and the team at SpaceX and want
to brush up on your skills in math,
computer science, and data science,
I highly recommend Brilliant, a website
and app where you can learn interactively.
And it’s FREE for you to try out.
Whether you’re aspiring to be part of
the next generation of space explorers,
or simply looking to enhance your
skills no matter your profession,
Brilliant’s interactive lessons
can help you on your journey.
I personally use Brilliant to go
through to improve my analytical
skills by going through their Logic puzzles.
There’s something for everyone
whether you’re starting out or
want to progress to more challenging puzzles.
And if you get stuck, you can view the
explanation to discover the correct approach.
You can try out Brilliant for
FREE for 30 days using my link
in the description: brilliant.org/newsthink.
If you’re one of the first 200
people to sign up via my link,
you’ll get 20% off your Premium subscription,
unlocking all of Brilliant's courses.